hace unas semanas de la vida de fiona
cambió radicalmente a principios de
marzo dejó parís para mudarse a venecia
hoy su traslado al trabajo es
completamente diferente lo que realmente
ha comido para mí es que antes tomaba
entre 50 y una hora en metro y tren
ahora son 15-20 minutos aquí por el
centro histórico de venecia y eso es muy
agradable vida un hermoso paseo diario
zona ahora trabaja de forma remota desde
venecia para su empleador con sede en
issy les moulineaux en los suburbios de
parís ella está en el primer grupo de
profesionales que forma parte de un
nuevo proyecto llamado wenni wear que
tienen como objetivo alentar a las
personas que teletrabajan a vivir en
venecia
estamos aquí para hacer exactamente el
mismo trabajo que haríamos en parís
además damos ejemplo a otras empresas y
demostramos que se puede enviar gente al
extranjero a trabajar de forma remota
que funcione que podemos ver resultados
los empleados están contentos y tal vez
se quedan más tiempo trabajando para la
empresa
la empresa brinda una variedad de
servicios a los posibles trabajadores
remotos como asistencia con el proceso
administrativo logística e incluso ayuda
a encontrar alojamiento
esta mañana un candidato potencial en
berlín está haciendo un recorrido
virtual por un apartamento
aquí hay una mesa de comedor y la sala
de estar
la luz es muy hermosa díaz windows si
las ventanas son realmente grandes y
desde aquí se ve la lagunita la col
1500 personas se han registrado en la
plataforma del proyecto sus creadores
esperan que ayude a reconsiderar el
modelo de desarrollo en venecia
como artista
nuestra ciudad de ha sufrido mucho por
el exceso de turismo es una ciudad que
se está despoblando queremos cambiar la
población de la ciudad gracias a un
flujo de nuevos residentes que ayuden a
compensar la grave crisis demográfica
que tenemos aquí pensar que lo que a su
progenitor han grave crisis demografía
de laxe está en los últimos 50 años
venecia ha perdido dos tercios de sus
habitantes una tendencia que este nuevo
proyecto espera revertir para repoblar
esta ciudad verdaderamente única